America's youth are hopelessly addicted
to Tech and it's only getting worse so
is it time for drastic measures a school
district in Massachusetts ban
smartphones for students and teachers
after realizing kids no longer knew how
to interact with one another due to
remote learning they still have access
to tablets and laptops during class but
the school argues they have seen both
academic and social life of the students
improve some kids in New York City
Bucking the trend ditching smartphones
for flip phones to disconnect from
social media so Kennedy is having a flip
phone like the new cool hip thing
absolutely not having a flip phone is
worse than going to Siberia like if I
really really wanted to punish my
children I would say okay one more time
you're getting a flip phone they'd be
like
they turn into nuns like their best
behavior I wish they didn't have
smartphones in school because they have
forgotten how to socialize they've
forgotten how to look people in the eye
and have conversations the pandemic was
so incredibly cruel for that reason
because it forced kids into their own
caves of solitude and it's really
difficult to unring that Bell but one
teacher told me that kids are mostly
texting with their moms no that their
moms are the ones who are distracting
themselves sorry on behalf of all moms I
apologize yeah so Tyrus it's interesting
to see how people think that taking away
a smartphone would be the end of the
world and yet it does actually improve
the mental health of students when
they're not on their phones yeah Mommy
can wait okay because you text Dad
during school day you're gonna have a
problem so here's the thing just take it
away kill the babysitter and it's not
just schools it's at home if you go if
if your household the only sound you
hear at the dinner table is fingers
texting or someone playing Roblox or
whatever you're just as guilty as
allowing it in the schools you got to
stop using social media and Technology
as the babysitter and actually do the
job and there's no place for a phone at
school not just the fact they're not
socializing it also leads to all
bullying and all kind of not being
included and they talk about whatever
they want everyone to feel well you
don't have a smartphone you have he has
an Android like all that stuff is
bullying and the text bullying is harder
for teachers to catch it it's you know
especially especially if you look at the
statistics especially for young girls
social media is like with boys The
Bullying usually is physical it's on the
school ground and they go home it's done
they get a break girls don't get a break
they'll go home and then their outfit
will get made fun of them being rated on
Facebook or whatever the cases may be so
you eliminate it you take it out it
literally like with my kids when I take
my stuff away it lasts about 15 minutes
of the world's over what am I gonna do
and I'll be like this thing out there
called the sun go stand under it figure
it out
yeah Jessica I mean it does especially
think seem like for young girls
they did not have Acts
arms all the time yeah it would be great
to not know how awkward you are right
and that's essentially what it's called
photos enough once a year okay I don't
need it to be all the time yeah I
I'm just so thankful to have not had it
at this level like we had computers and
we got an email address my freshman year
of high school and you had to check it
once a day to see if a teacher had sent
out something and you would dial up when
you got home and you legitimately if you
told your parents I have to be on the
computer it's for homework the computer
was in the kitchen yeah and they could
watch you right what are you doing and
you couldn't hide your AOL chat room or
whatever you were pretending that you
were doing in there and it's very
upsetting people always enjoy it like
even for us unplugging on a vacation
writing I'm actually going away I think
you did this when you took a week off
recently where you were like I'm not
going to be online it's healthy for all
of us certainly to remedy what went on
the pandemic but just to be better
humans I mean walking around everyone is
looking down the subway which I mean
it's not great for a whole host of
reasons but you used to sit down there
and smile at people and like ask people
about their books it sounds hokey but it
was part of the fun of no more smiling
on the subway I still Sean we're talking
about kids here teenagers college
students maybe but I know some adults
who have a hard hard time giving up
their phone I don't think it's just kids
everyone's addicted to them and by the
way we're all more depressed we're all
more isolated and the phones are causing
it I think what a great idea to say for
this little space in time seven hours a
day we can give kids a respite from
their phones and actually engage engage
and engage each other that's wonderful
so for me I have nine kids and what's
beautiful is I make mistakes with the
early ones and I fix it later so the
first four I gave phones to and you know
when they're 13 14 15 and they all
promise they're going to be responsible
and only for school and uh because they
get pressure safety I got no well I want
to be able to reach out to them and call
them if something goes wrong but they
convinced me and I bought it that they
were gonna you know buy by the rules we
set and so now my fifth child she's 14
and she begs and she enlists her other
family you know brothers and sisters to
help get us to get our phone and I'm
like hell no you are not gonna have a
phone and I'll offer you a flip phone if
you want one and by the way she doesn't
want to the phone I don't want one it's
usually the opposite like you're too
harsh on the older ones the younger ones
get the leniency yeah when I retire I'm
getting a rotary phone so it's only
catching I've got no phone I'm real you
only catch me between when I'm in the
house you don't catch me in the house
you ain't catching I'm getting a pigeon
carrier no one's that important the
fastest is up next